[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Material design is alive,
and it lives in a world a lot
like ours, a world that's
responsive, natural, aware,
and intentional.
Material design uses responsive
animation to create energy.
When you take an action,
feedback is immediate,
and it never keeps you waiting.
Motion adapts to the distance
an element needs to travel,
focusing on how fast
something needs to move,
rather than how long it
should take to get there.
Motion should feel
natural, moving the way
things do in the real world.
Nothing should
instantly start or stop.
Elements and motion have
momentum and take time
to speed up and slow down.
They respond to
forces like gravity,
moving in curved paths,
instead of in straight lines.
Material is also aware
of the world around it.
The way something
enters the screen
can affect the movement
of everything else.
Elements can push other
elements out of the way,
or attract them.
Above all, material
isn't random.
There's a purpose
behind every animation.
Motion guides you.
It keeps you focused
on what's important
and makes sure you
don't get lost.
It also hints at how
something might react,
even before it's triggered.
Whether your brand
is fun and playful,
or serious and straightforward,
using the motion principles
for material design can help
you produce a quick, clear,
and cohesive experience.
Get to know how things
move at design.google.com.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Hi.
I'm John Schlemmer.
I'm the motion lead on
the Material Design team
here at Google.
I authored the
new motion section
that can be found in the
material design guidelines
at design.google.com.
And before that, I also led
the motion efforts for apps
like Inbox and Calendar.
So I'm here to talk to
you about motion design.
Motion is becoming more and
more prominent in apps today.
And it's really one of
the key giveaways of what
makes a high quality app.
And it's also one of the
main components of what
makes material, material.
So we touched on some motion
in our design guidelines
when we introduced material
at I/O about two years ago.
Now, there are over a
million material design
apps in the Play Store.
And it's really exciting to
see how designers and engineers
have been using the system.
These new motion guidelines
that were released last week
go really in-depth
and, hopefully,
provide solutions to
many of the challenges
that you've been
facing around motion.
Advanced animation in
UI is still, generally,
a pretty new thing.
And we really wanted to try
to capture what works and what
doesn't.
It's really hard to
describe or pinpoint
what exactly doesn't feel right
when a transition isn't working
the way you thought it would.
What's worse, motion can be
abused, just like Photoshop
filters.
It's really easy to go
overboard or spend time
implementing the wrong thing.
And that's what these
new material motion
guidelines will help you with.
We wanted to find a way to
think about how material
moves, while, at the
same time just thinking
about general good UX practices,
when it comes to motion.
These guidelines can really
help you get your branded motion
to feel right-- suggested
durations, easing
curves for different
kinds of movement,
how to choreograph shared
elements between views,
and how material interacts
with other material, and so on.
A common misconception
about motion
is that it's just about polish.
And it's not really
fair to group all motion
into just the polish category.
There are certain
levels of motion
that are key components
to making a great app,
and it does so much more
than just polish it.
It can guide users
to the next view.
It can convey hierarchy
and spatial relationships
between both objects
on and off screen.
It can help foreshadow what
a particular gesture might
trigger before you
actually trigger it.
It can help distract
you, in a good way,
from things like
loading or fetching
content, things you don't
really want to have noticed.
And of course, it can
add delight and polish.
But by doing that,
all of these things
together just make a feeling
of a really high quality app.
And if this is
done right, you'll
be left with a really
solid animation experience
throughout your app
or family of apps.
So let's take a look at the
Google Calendar animation
for opening and
closing an event.
Those of you that
probably use Calendar
will be pretty
familiar with this.
A lot of you
probably don't really
think about this anymore.
It's just opening
and closing an event.
Happens all the time.
But there are a lot of really
subtle things happening here
to help you understand
hierarchy and order,
to make sure you don't
get lost and using it.
What if this didn't have
an animation at all?
Without an animation
here, it's really hard
to tell what was triggered,
where you ended up,
and where the view
that you just left
lives in relation to this
new view that's there.
Loading also stands
out a lot more,
because there's nothing
really there to mask it.
All right, so this is a
pretty extreme comparison.
So let's find an
in-between solution.
Let's look at what this would be
using just a default transition
and not really taking into
account the new principles we
have.
Sure, it feels a little
better, but it's still not
really communicating anything.
The view just kind of
slides in from the bottom.
There's still no relationship
between the object that
was tapped and the
new view coming in.
There are a lot of subtleties
in animation techniques used
to get this calendar transition
to feel just smooth and right.
And today, I'd like to go
over these motion principles.
I'll loop back to this Calendar
transition towards the end,
just to show exactly where
these principles come into play,
and just how they were
used as building blocks
to create the
transition we landed on.
So let's dive into
the new guidelines.
When writing these
guidelines, we really
wanted to dig deep and find
out how material moves.
And as you saw in the
video at the beginning,
material in motion
is responsive,
its natural, it's aware,
and it's intentional.
And all of these are
definitely loaded words.
There's a lot of meaning
behind each one of them,
but they're all equally
important principles
that make up material.
And I'd like to briefly
go over each one.
First, material is responsive.
And responsive can also mean
a lot of things, especially
in the world of responsive
design and different screen
sizes.
It's a pretty overloaded term.
But when it comes to motion,
it means it immediately
and quickly responds
to your touch.
In material, this response is
in the form of an ink ripple
and a change in elevation,
like when you tap a button.
The ink ripple forms
in the exact location
that you interacted with it.
And the element's shadow
signifies that it's actually
rising to your touch.
It's like a form of response.
It also means new
surfaces can quickly
be created from that
precise touch location
too, like menus when
you tap an icon.
And it never keeps you waiting.
People use our apps
to get things done.
The example on the
right is actually
something you want to avoid.
If it takes too long, it'll
look really old, really fast.
To give you an idea,
typical transitions
we've used on mobile devices
have about a 300 to 350
millisecond duration.
That's pretty quick.
That's a third of a second.
But it's also not
a duration that
should be used for everything.
It totally depends on how
far something needs to travel
or how much change is.
Tablet screens, for
example may need
to have a slightly
longer duration,
like 400 to 450
milliseconds, to make up
for that overall
greater distance
that it actually
needs to travel.
Smaller screens,
like on a watch,
obviously need to move
really short distances.
It's a pretty small screen.
These are often in the range
of 150 to 200 milliseconds.
On web, durations
and animations,
in general, are treated
a little differently.
There's a general
perception on web for things
to just be lightning fast.
And it's because, when
you navigate websites,
there's usually no
transition that takes you
from one page to the next page.
Most websites aren't cohesive
app-like experiences.
So when you do have one of
those cohesive experiences,
you still want your
transitions to feel
like they belong on the
web, like they're still
lightning fast.
Inboxes on web, for example,
uses 150 millisecond duration
in its main opening and
closing email transition.
Well, on mobile, it actually
uses 300 millisecond.
That means the web durations
are twice as fast, even
though the screen's bigger.
Sometimes, animations need
to be modified a bit too,
to account for these
faster transitions.
Implying an object
needs to make a big move
or expands into a
bigger card is actually
different than
physically drawing
each frame of that animation.
There's a bit of
magic that motion
can imply that kind of
lets your imagination fill
in the in-between frames.
Another thing to keep in mind
is staggering content in a view.
Staggering a list of grid
items as they travel on screen
is a pretty common practice.
And it can look
really good, too.
But each item should have
a very, very short delay
between entrances.
You definitely do not
want to wait for each item
to finish entering, before
getting the next one in there.
Otherwise, especially
for longer list items,
you're going to be waiting a
long time for that last one
to populate.
We found it's best to begin
each staggered transition no
more than 20 to 25
milliseconds apart.
It's short, but it makes sense.
And I'll get more
into staggering orders
and choreography later on.
So let's look at
the next principle.
Material is natural.
The movement of
material is inspired
by forces in our real world, so
things like gravity, friction,
momentum, and so on.
Momentum is a pretty big one.
Nothing in our
world can actually
instantly start or stop.
It depends on weight
and surface friction.
So it only makes sense
for on-screen material
to follow these same rules.
This is where our fine-tuned
easing curves really
come into play.
Easing is used to add
acceleration and deceleration
to any type of movement.
What's more, our easing curves
are actually asymmetrical.
This means that each end
of the curve is different.
Let's see how this affects
some of the curves we
cover in the guidelines.
The material standard
curve is used for objects
moving from one
on-screen location
to another on-screen location,
and also transforming
from one size to another size.
Easing is at both
ends of the curve,
but it accelerates a little
bit faster than it slows down.
This gives the feeling
that it's really energetic.
It's really excited to
get to the next spot.
It leaps into
motion, but it still
needs to take some
time to slow down.
The deceleration curve is used
for objects entering the screen
from an offscreen location.
The acceleration is instant.
Since this is the part that
actually happens offscreen,
you don't see it.
The gradual deceleration matches
that of the standard curve.
This gives the illusion that
it's zooming in at full speed
from somewhere off the screen.
And we don't really
care where it came from,
we just care where it ends up.
The acceleration curve is used
for objects exiting the screen.
The acceleration is gradual,
just like the standard curve.
But the deceleration is instant,
since this is now the part
that you don't see.
This gives the illusion
that it's zooming out
of the screen at full
speed, and we don't really
care where it stops.
Another concept
we're introducing
is what we call arc motion.
Forces like gravity can affect
how an object moves up or down.
This results in objects moving
in slightly curved paths,
instead of in straight lines.
Doing this makes
diagonal movements
feel a little less robotic
and a little more natural.
This concept is also represented
in transforming surfaces.
So by slightly offsetting
the width and height
transformation, you get the same
kind of curved expansion path.
And when objects inside of
the surface use the same path,
it results in a really nicely
choreographed transition.
And I'll get to that in a bit.
Next, material is aware.
It's aware of objects around
it, behind it, in front of it,
and even within it.
This allows for a really
nice choreographed motion
that involve a lot of different
UI elements at the same time.
As elements
transition into view,
they take into account
the relationships
with other objects
around them, and they
move in a way that
demonstrates this hierarchy.
This kind of connected movement
gives a really nice story
about where these objects
live and, hopefully,
a better understanding of how
the app is actually structured.
Surfaces can also push other
surfaces out of the way.
So if you're familiar with
material's elevation story,
it describes how each object
is at a different elevation.
So it only makes sense
that, if two cards are
on the same elevation, and
one happens to expand or move,
it would actually need to
push that other card out
of the way to make room for it.
Either that, or it would need
to rise above that other card,
so it doesn't need to
push it out of the way.
The important thing
to note here is
material can't pass
through other material.
It knows it needs to do
something to make room for it
to move.
Another concept of awareness
is a form of magnetism.
This can be a really
powerful mechanism
in interaction design.
And it can really help
define relationships
and signify whether
or not objects
are able to interact
with each other.
In this example, that circle is
able to interact with the other
smaller circles around it.
And as it approaches each
one, they're able to attach.
Once they move
away, they detach.
It kind of makes you
feel like the UI is
doing its best to understand
what you want to do.
So last, let's get
into intention.
Everything material
does is intentional.
Every movement has a purpose.
And its purpose is
to guide you, it's
to make sure you don't get
lost when you're using the app.
The best way to do
this, we've found,
is to have common shared
elements between views.
If you're animating from
a transition from point A
to point B, there's
more often than not
a common shared element
that's present in both views.
In this case, we have the
avatar in the collapsed card
and also in the expanded card.
All the other content
changes, but the avatar
is what stays consistent here.
So when we make
this transition, we
keep this visible at all times.
The avatar acts as
the focal point,
and it guides you
to the next view,
right where your
attention should end up.
So when we pair this with the
asymmetrical width and height
transformation of
the card's surface
and add that curved
path to the avatar,
we get this really nice,
natural expansion and collapse.
So as a warning,
though, it's really easy
to go overboard here.
What if you have a lot of
elements in both views?
If you have too
many, your focus is
pulled in 100
different directions,
and it's really hard to
pinpoint what exactly it
was you needed to follow.
It's OK not to keep
every element consistent.
And the example on the left
is a good way to handle this.
So we touched on staggering
the entrance of elements
a little earlier.
We talked about how to quickly
stagger multiple elements.
But the order in which
they appear on screen
is just as important.
The idea is to
guide your attention
in one fluid direction.
A single column with stagger
is pretty straightforward.
Top to bottom usually
makes the most sense here.
There's usually not a reason
you should veer from this.
Changing this up feels
pretty unnatural,
and you're scattered
in different directions
throughout the stagger.
It also doesn't really
help your hierarchy story.
Having everything appear
on screen at the same time
isn't exactly that
much better either.
Staggering grid views is
a little more complicated.
It might not actually be
what you'd expect at first.
If you have a grid view with
multiple columns and rows,
you want to look
at the treatment
of the grid as a
whole and present it
in a nice diagonal motion,
instead of introducing row
by row.
If you stagger an entire row
before starting the next one,
you get this kind of zigzag
of attention guidance.
Plus, it actually takes longer,
if you have a pretty big grid,
to get to that
bottom right corner.
If you stagger from the top
left to the bottom right
of the whole grid, you get this
really nice constant direction
from start to finish.
Another material
intention is to let
you know what's going to
happen before it happens.
This comes in handy
with gestures a lot.
For example, if you're using an
app where your key interaction
is to swipe things
away, what happens
when you run into an item
that you can't actually swipe?
You want to add
resistance to that item
to signify that
it's not available.
Resistance has to do
with how much that
object moves in relation
to how far you drag it.
That way, the user
immediately knows
what they're trying to do
isn't available here, even
before they complete the swipe.
The items that can be
swiped have no resistance
and are much easier
to move around.
It's kind of like it's inviting
you to interact with it.
So those are the four
principles of material motion:
responsive, natural,
aware, and intentional.
By following these
guidelines, you're
left with transitions that
have a few key characteristics.
And this is actually
a really great way
to judge whether
or not you ended up
doing the right thing
for your motion design.
The transitions are quick.
Things happen fast, so the
user doesn't have to wait.
The animation on the left users
our suggested durations, which
is about 350 milliseconds.
The one on the right, doesn't.
It's about 600 milliseconds.
It still looks nice,
but it's pretty slow.
It's only a third
of a second longer,
but you can see how
big of a difference
it makes, especially if you're
doing this over and over again.
Next, the transitions are clear.
This plays on the guided
focus and natural behavior
of material a little bit.
In the animation on the left,
you can really easily follow
the path of the expanding card.
The one on the right isn't
really that easy to follow.
It's fast, so it follows
that, but your focus
is shifted in like
every direction.
Providing a clear focus
really goes a long way here.
Lastly, the transitions
are cohesive.
So here are three apps that
do very different things,
but all of them follow
these motion guidelines.
Motion can really
unify experiences
throughout a family of apps
and make them feel related.
So let's go back to
that calendar transition
from the beginning.
Now that we know what we're
looking for, we can identify
this transition and why it
feels right, and compare it
to a simple slide-in,
or no transition at all.
First, it's responsive.
We have that ink splash,
signifying that we tapped it.
And we have that nice shadow
coming from behind the chip
to signify elevation.
Next, it's natural.
So we have these nice easing
curves and arc motion going
throughout that transition.
Third, it's aware.
It knows that it needs to
lift above the other chips
to make room for it.
But it also knows what is at
that new elevation it just
moved to, like that
app bar at the top.
It collides with the app
bar to push it off screen,
and it pulls it back down
when it collapses again.
Last, it's intentional.
We use a shared element, the
event image in this case,
to guide you to the
top of the next view,
exactly where you
should end up looking.
It completes the
story of hierarchy.
And the other
objects around it are
choreographed in a way that kind
of follows this motion with it.
So that's how these principles
built our view transition
in Calendar.
But let's not forget the polish
details I talked about earlier.
These are still important.
Add in some animation where
the user might enjoy it,
or might not expect it,
like changing the icon
of a button when you tap it.
Reaching Inbox 0 is a
pretty big achievement,
so let's make a big
deal about it, right?
Maybe it'll encourage
you to keep it up,
which is, coincidentally, how
we want you to use the app.
Or maybe you want to call
out a new feature in an app,
like adding pit stops to Maps.
And you really want to show off
all of the different things you
can do with it, without having
a bunch of paragraphs of text
to explain it.
Error states are another
really fun place to do this.
So an error is never really
something you want to see.
But honestly, this kind of
makes you feel better about it.
[LAUGHTER]
So with all that said, I'm
going to wrap up a little early.
I encourage you to check
out the motion guidelines
at design.google.com.
They're found in the
material design resources
when you go there.
It covers everything I talked
about today and a lot more.
And I'm really excited to see
what everybody comes up with.
If you'd like to have
a chat about motion,
or anything else
design-related for that matter,
there's a material design
sandbox south of here,
in that direction.
I'm going to head
over there right now.
But it's the end
of the day, so I
don't think we're going to
do anymore reviews today.
But I am going to be there,
along with my other co-workers,
Thursday and Friday.
And since we're there
for the whole show,
giving design reviews, I
figured it's a great place
to have a conversation, instead
of having a formal Q&A here.
So I definitely
encourage you to come by,
if there any questions you want
to have answered about motion.
And also, congratulations
on surviving your first day
at I/O. Right?
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, so much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]